anybody has anything first I'll just see
who would like to speak on it here
.
this is the chiropractor one that's the
animal right so I thought we were going
to the reason why we had waited was
because we were waiting to hear from one
of the boards
and they're here okay cool so if you
could come up
Chiropractic thing first correct
thank you uh chairman likes just just
for to be correct I'm not with the board
I'm a lobbyist representing the New
Hampshire State chiropractor first of
all if I could get your I'm sorry Simon
Thompson with no p t h o m s o n
um
I think what we were to your point
representative go to what you guys were
holding off of is on February 15th the
board of veterinary medicine met
uh I did not attend that but oplc staff
person uh Elizabeth Eaton did uh email
me their position and suggested language
I don't know did you get that Mr
chairman I don't believe so okay I I
have one copy and I'm happy to give it
to you but I'll read what they said and
again I don't represent them I'm just
stating the facts
statement on House Bill 258 and again
this is from the board of veterinary
medicine the board opposes this bill as
written the practice of using human
modalities on animals needs to be
addressed as a whole and this bill is
not sufficient an animal can currently
receive Chiropractic Care from a
licensed veterinarian so trained
should the committee still desire to
pursue this bill we propose the
committee adopt the amendment attached
the board would add referral language as
follows and here's what they recommend
amend 258
by replacing the bill entirely with the
following New Hampshire veterinary
Practice Act license required and
exceptions amend RSA 332b colon 2 to add
the following after subsection X and
this is the meat of it a chiropractor
licensed under RSA 316a that's our scope
of practice
providing chiropractic care to animals
that's what the bills trying to do
provided the animal chiropractor Prior
to treating receives a referral from a
veterinarian licensed under RSA
332-b again that's what the board of
veterinary medicine would like to see we
are fine with that language as a
Chiropractic Association because what it
does is it we get a referral from
somebody who's licensed and trained to
care for animals saying they need to
have chiropractic care and so that's in
any chiropractor can can then do that
all right thank you if you can leave
that up actually first if any does
so for clarification you're saying that
human chiropractors will not treat
animals unless they have a referral from
a veterinarian that says that that's
what they would that's what my
Association would like to see yes okay
and then the only other thing I'll
mention if if I may is there was some
talk about another uh Amendment
dealing with
um again provided by oplc
um same same section of the law statute
this is just a different wording an
individual certified to provide animal
Chiropractic Services by a board
recognized National certification body
that's the other thing that we would be
fine with the problem with that is the
veterinarians don't want to be uh
responsible for certifying whatever
National Organization is so I think
that's why they preferred their language
that I read to you probably okay any
oh
So when you say human chiropractor I
only have one I'll give I'll bring it
closer you know I have when you say
human chiropractor I assume the animal
chiropractor and human chiropractors are
both human So when you say when you say
human chiropractor do you mean
I think she means people people who are
licensed one that works on people or one
or an animal chiropractor who is a human
come on
no I'm not trying to be funny I was I
yeah all right yeah so
I mean clearly clearly
this is animal chiropractors people who
are like sorry people who are licensed
to practice Chiropractic and human
humans
um and presumably they have some other
training to practice on animals as well
maybe certification but uh
apparently the veterinary board would
like a situation where if anybody is
going to do Chiropractic on animals
they'd want to referral from a vet I
think that's that's the position so
um
and you know I assume that's the correct
but if not correct me right the only
thing I would just maybe correct a
little bit is there is I mean there is
chiropractors out there that do get
training for for treating animals but
that's few and far between
um so that's why the majority of
chiropractors and that's from both
organizations uh would support this
because they don't mind letting
chiropractors Care for Animals they just
want a veterinarian to refer them or to
have some sort of national certification
prior to being able to treat because
they have no training most chiropractors
have no training to care for animals so
if somebody just brings an animal in and
this chiropractor
treats it and does something wrong with
no certification or no referral from a
vet that's going to be a black mark on
the industry represent goalie Schmidt
thank you Mr chair so what I'm hearing
is we want both the referral and some
sort of certification in animal
Chiropractic because that would be ideal
two totally different
and and and and and again I can provide
this language both both amendments where
you would be where you would put that
which again is under the Veterinarian
Practice Act thank you
representative Schmidt thank you Mr
chairman well uh there are two questions
that immediately arise
uh what is the referring
referring vet going to charge if
anything
uh for this referral and secondly if
it's as we've been told very difficult
to get a an appointment to see a vet now
we're talking about an animal that is
suffering uh and and there is a there is
relief available on in the on the per in
the person or the on the part of a
trained certified animal chiropractor uh
and that person uh is is going to be
hanging out there unable to act until
they get this referral
how many how many days or weeks is the
animal supposed to suffer while that
referral process goes through and what
is the cost going to be I don't see that
that's really not either workable at all
or
not bound up in a lot of delays and and
in the meantime it could go
you go to the animal chiropractor as
soon as he or she's available you get
the service and this
so so if I may the workability is very
much in doubt in my mind if I may
address that and just to be clear again
I I do not speak for the veterinarians
so I can't answer what it would cost to
get a referral or the time frame
into representative goalie's point a
question
if you don't want the referral
from the veterinarian you think that's
too unworkable then then language that
would still be under the Veterinarian
Practice Act that states an individual
certified to provide animal Chiropractic
Services by a board recognized National
certification body then we're fine again
you don't want somebody to just bring an
animal into a chiropractor who's not had
any training or certification treating a
chiropractor that's not what we want
okay just I'll get your mom I just have
a quick question that is
um so if we just said any nationally
certified or nationally recognized
certification body for animal
Chiropractic they don't want to get in
the business of picking one or
overseeing it or anything but if we said
anyone or we specified one then that
would be that that board and the
Chiropractic people would be okay with
that again I can't speak for the
veterinarian board but we would be okay
with that again under making sure that
it's under the Veterinarian Practice Act
which is RSA 332b representative goalie
thank you Mr chair my only concern
without having a referral is we're now
having
individual pet owners trying to diagnose
the problem with their animal and the
chiropractic care may not be what's best
for that animal at the time and that's
the concern I have with no referral or
no looking at the animal before sending
Chiropractic Care thank you I understand
that and uh
but
what I would say is I mean people end up
in effect diagnosing the animals before
they decide to take them anywhere and if
the I would think if the person
practicing animal Chiropractic was
certified they could should be able to
recognize that they're not able to help
this animal
that's you know if I may Mr chair that's
that's a good point I mean if your dog's
limping and you think it's you know pull
the muscle or something and you bring it
in and it's actually a tumor because
it's cancer you know the chiropractor is
not going to be able to figure that out
uh unless they've had the proper
training and certification that opens up
a big amount of liability okay
um
I saw you but is there anyone else here
uh
I was just gonna if you will I'll leave
this with you yeah I think I have one of
them but I'm not sure I have the other
one
good morning uh and thank you for
hearing
um my testimony I am here on behalf of
the board of veterinary medicine my name
is Elizabeth Eaton I am board Council
and I work for oplc
um so
we had a meeting on Wednesday during
which the the veterinarian board
discussed this at length so I can speak
a little bit I did share with Simon and
so I think he uh spoke a little bit on
what the the veterinarian board
provided for written testimony but I can
answer some questions based on their
discussion as well
Reverend Schmidt or well were you here
for my questions uh I was here let's
hear some of your questions towards the
end you're
referral
correct well I'm troubled by by the
potential unlikely delay that would be
involved we heard in when the bill was
first heard that it's very difficult to
get an appointment with a Veterinary
that's what we heard okay so secondly
even if it's even if you can get one
it's likely going to be a delay involved
and and this is going to be the Cairo
the veterinarian presumably is going to
examine the uh the animal and then make
the referral if this is something which
is
something which we would require or
benefit from this animal chiropractor
right
but the delay aspect for an animal is
suffering it was it troubles me as much
as for a human being that's suffering
that's sitting in the waiting room or
can't get the appointment
suffering is not a good idea we want to
alleviate that eliminate that we can so
the delay aspect is troubling uh and and
the question is uh what is the the what
is the cost going to be for the
veterinarian to uh to observe something
and it could could well be now that you
have somebody who knows what the
situation is because it has occurred in
the past they know that they need the
animal chiropractor right so the
referral is probably not really
necessary at least hypothetically and so
forth so the workability aspect of the
proposal of getting from here to
Manchester by way of Los Angeles uh is
is of serious concern and and and I
think there are several of us on the
committee I'm not on the subcommittee
but we're allowed to participate
nevertheless as a member of the
committee uh that really want to see
this animal Chiropractic be available
expeditiously and without additional
unreasonable cost so and I would like to
hear from my colleagues
as well first but first I completely
agree with you I have the same concerns
um
and at least offhand maybe somebody has
another data I see um
two solutions I'm not sure who they
would make happy or unhappy but um one
is to put something in the the
veterinary act saying basically that the
veterinary board
does not uh regulate in any way uh
people in the practice of animal
Chiropractic period
and then it's going to be a matter of
you know if people want to check if
someone who's practicing animal
Chiropractic is nationally certified
they can do that or have a referral for
someone else who's had good experience
with their animal and if they're not
happy they can not go back and if
they're really not happy and think their
animal got harmed they can sue them like
you know
similarly if you're you know you get
your car repaired in a car shop and you
think they did a terrible job
it's really no difference and I think
the risk in the animal side if anything
is less because not going to cause a car
accident it's going to kill people
so that's one option I see the other
option
would be to um
require
some form of the nationally recognized
certification and I I do not want to get
into a whole occupational licensing for
animal chiropractors I just don't want
to go there see what other people think
um
so either we could just say you know and
I'm asking you because you're the only
person I think here from oplc you might
have some input
um either say any nationally recognized
you know
um the outfit that certifies people who
do animal Chiropractic and maybe some
language or leave it up to oplc you know
the administrative side not the board
because the vet board doesn't want to do
this to to name ones I know there are
some okay
um
or name them in statute but that's
generally a bad idea because then the
names change and more come up and all
that so what's your take on that yeah
I'm I'm I agree with you on on not
putting into the statute whether there's
any kind of certifications but to back
up
um to your to your first
um to to back up to your first proposal
that would be the the vet board's ideal
situation to just have
um nothing to do with animal
Chiropractic in their practice act
whatsoever however
um just to back up even further
um currently in the The Practice Act for
the board of veterinary medicine there's
a statute that deals with animal
Physical Therapy already so
um using human modalities on animals is
becoming more and more common first
Physical Therapy appears in The Practice
Act and now animal Chiropractic is is
proposed appear in the in the Practice
Act uh the the board of veterinary
medicine made it clear that these
modalities are are already being used by
licensed veterinarians
a referral may not be necessary if the
the veterinarian themselves already does
animal chiropractic care or animal
Physical Therapy the board would like to
address these human modalities as a
whole rather than piecemeal Physical
Therapy here Chiropractic Care here and
um perhaps there could be a more General
statutory amendment that would allow
rulemaking to address these human
modalities used with animals the board
is concerned about just exempting animal
Chiropractic Care from the the
definition of veterinary medicine
without some sort of referral and in the
physical therapy statute
the the animal has to have a referral to
get animal physical therapy and there's
a whole process by which that referral
is made it can be uh called in on the
phone
very quickly and Then followed up with a
written referral uh so it it I do
understand the time constraint and and
watching an animal suffer or anyone
suffer is not anything that the
veterinarian board wants they do just
want a high standard of care
for these animals wherever they're being
seen
representative goalie oh sorry I don't
know who went well representative a bear
in today's current law with oplc in who
you license you license doctors yes
correct you license chiropractors yes
and today if I want to go to
a chiropractor as a human being I do not
need a referral is that correct
I I can't speak to each individual
chiropractor and some insurance
companies do require referrals from
Physicians so it depends I can answer
that question for you if you don't mind
certainly so I am a patient for
the
um for a chiropractor in Salem and I
can't remember the name of it right now
it's a chain
um but I can go in there without a
doctor's referral and I can be treated
I don't see where there's any alignment
if humans are in the hierarchy of
um humans and animals right
um
I don't see a problem with not having a
referral for an animal as these
chiropractors are all certified
they
when you go into a chiropractor they
will not treat you if they think you
have a potential corroded artery right
they want to send you for a
ultrasound or whatever they may so I
I
am just trying to say that we should
align the law with exactly where we are
in New Hampshire now without a referral
thank you
I don't disagree with you except that
the the chiropractors are licensed and
under the jurisdiction of the board of
chiropractic care and animals
fall under the board of veterinary
medicine for most
situations there there are some that are
exempt
specifically horse massage equine
um other equine modalities
there's a very few things that are
exempt from the the practice of
veterinary medicine but the the rest is
under their jurisdiction and so if any
um
an animal suffers at the hand of a vet
veterinarian their owner or someone else
can file a complaint with the board of
veterinary medicine and and they may
um
follow up with that licensing board
for accountability the chiropractors
additionally can have are accountable to
the board of chiropractic medicine
in an animal chiropractor would
would be
you know under this statute as uh
as introduced
would fall under neither
or if there were
an exemption it would fall under
licensed chiropractors so it's it's
really unclear who would be holding
um
representative goalie
thank you Mr chair and
I just want to make sure I heard
correctly so for physical therapy and
modalities they need referrals correct
and Chiropractic Care would be similar
to
physical therapy and working on
modalities and that nature
are similar I've been chiropractic care
and physical therapies are are similar
representative Schmidt let's just thank
you Mr chairman so
um
the thing is that it strikes me that if
we can figure out some kind of a a
modality whereby the
the veterinary
field in the practice of veterinary
medicine
perhaps could be involved for an initial
referral
and then subsequently
they would they would never have to go
back to the chiropra to the vet again
for an additional referral
uh then and that would solve some of the
problem because one of the things that
we've heard is that in the past
and not recent past as I understand it
the some of these animal chiropractors
were getting cease and desist letters
from vets or veterinarian like the board
boards whatever
um and they that they were the animal
chiropractors were getting intimidated
because they were getting threatened by
it all
uh and so that's not a good situation
but but what I've heard is it's not
happening currently there haven't been
any of these decent resist orders
recently so
is this a is this really a problem that
needs to be fixed
that we that should lurk in the back of
our minds as a as a fact that we we want
to consider I think what we did here was
that um there are people doing animal
Chiropractic who are
concerned about their status they aren't
expanding their business they're not
advertising
um because there is a history of of that
and they're concerned um
so let me ask you again if we decided to
not have
um
animal Chiropractic under the vet board
and not do licensing for it but
require that if somebody's going to
practice it they uh have some nationally
recognized certification
is there a place where that could fit in
in the oplc statute and with oplc you
know
be okay just
you know picking ones that seem to be
functional or competent
I I can't speak to oplc as an agency in
general I'm I'm only here on behalf of
the board of veterinary medicine and not
oplc as an agency
um if you're if you're
I I don't see putting it anywhere
besides either the veterinary Practice
Act or the chiropractor Practice Act I
don't see it having a place in the oplc
Statute in general
um
at this point but I can't speak for the
agency okay thank you
um any other discussion
yep representative crota
so it looks like
your situation we have two boards that
really don't want to
take on the responsibility as requested
in the legislature
and this
sort of puts us in a quandary
so
I do feel that your question about
certification
is a legitimate one and my
recommendation is that we wait for oplc
to respond to that
because this is not an early I mean you
know we've got to actually I you know
that makes a lot of sense
um yeah I could see I know
representative
trouble hearing um
so what I can do what I'll do if people
are okay with it is I will uh contact
Lindsay Courtney
raise the issue and uh see if
you know that's something that they
could do to to pick a board
um or you know certification outfit one
or more of them and then get her a
suggestion if they will do that on on
where to put the language and what the
language would be
represent goalie thank you Mr chair and
I'd also like to see copies of the
suggested language that we had before
from Simon
if you have those in electronic form
uh you could just send it to the whole
committee actually probably work
all right
uh yes
well I guess uh Diane wants to speak as
well that's fine once again Simon
Thompson with the New Hampshire State
Chiropractic Society just want to
reference what representative a bear
said and that's not a that's not an
Apples to Apples comparison when you say
a human can go to a chiropractor without
a referral from a doctor that is correct
that is true
chiropractors go to school to learn how
to treat humans that's the only training
they get
so if you now say that a chiropractor
with zero training can see animals
without a referral that is not what the
industry wants and the industry would be
totally against that I understand that
great and representative uh thank you
and and then and then just I'll
reiterate I think you've heard it but I
got to read it we do not want the
Chiropractic scope of care opened up and
put anything it's not looking to do that
thank you Mr I'm not all right
I apologize this is a passionate subject
of mine
um I just wanted to address a couple of
points um can you bring that closer yeah
Pull It Forward and yeah I have this
mortifying fear of microphones
um so yes indeed human chiropractors are
considered
um
human chiropractors are considered
primary care doctors and therefore don't
you don't need a referral but one of the
things that just strikes me is so absurd
while there are so many is that one can
take one's five-year-old child to a
chiropractor you can take a two-year-old
child to a chiropractor without
pediatric referral and the two-year-old
isn't communicating any better than my
dog possibly less well my dog
communicates really well
um
so so that's one issue just to address
that first I mean
I think
you know other people who testified said
the difference is and and actually I'm
on board with you as far as medium
referrals or even any kind of Licensing
but
um the difference is that the
Chiropractic person who practices on
humans
has had training as under opl Cena's
license and all of that whereas uh
currently the people that are doing
Chiropractic on animals are not and so
that I think they're and let me know if
I'm speaking you know wrong for you but
uh I think their view is that
um you don't need the referral for the
human because the person they're going
to is licensed and has to be trained in
all of that or is the one for the animal
may not be right and so I'm perfectly on
board with the idea not crazy about it
because I prefer your method but I am on
board with the idea of requiring
chiropractors to who treat animals to
have some sort of training or
certification in animal treatment I
personally I've seen many animal
chiropractors I mean I had my dog has
and I have never dealt with one who is
not either certified in animal
Chiropractic or
um was a veterinarian who also had
animal chiropractic training so I can't
speak to the the idea that there are
people out there homeless people who
wander into a shop and rent a place and
say let me treat animals so I'm on board
with the idea of of treatment but I I
bristled a little bit at the idea of
choosing one because I think there are
several good board-certified animal
chiropractic training things so that's
one it was mentioned that let me get on
that one if I can deal with them you
know individually and again if anybody
else wants to speak that let me know I
think the deal there is we we don't want
to be doing that and what I'm looking to
do and I'll ask executive director
Courtney if it would work would be to
leave it to oplc to list come up with a
list of acceptable
um certification organizations I mean
assuming there are more than one which I
guess there are
um it was mentioned that veterinarians
can do some of these modalities well
currently veterinarians or
other chiropractors I believe can do a I
think it's four to five hour training
program and call themselves
chiropractors and I I've seen the
difference it's not the same the
training they get is not the same thing
that quick training is not the same
thing as a qualified chiropractor so
that's that
um and then another thing that just
drives me nuts in the world of animals
is that currently
you can take a dog who's limping and
ignore them until it's so bad you have
to have them put to sleep or something
you don't with a five-year-old in
kindergarten if the child's in pain and
they go to a public school someone's
going to see it and parents will be
required to treat it or whatever but I'm
Blown Away Tony knows I happen to be
vegan and and really into animals and I
but the point is and and I wish everyone
on the planet were like me and if I
could be king everyone would be but
since they're not Tony's like thank God
but
um but the fact is animals are not
we don't regulate Animal Care the same
way if I have a dog who's limping I'm
free to just choose to ignore it until
at some point there may be animal
cruelty laws I don't know the details on
enforcement on that very true but right
now currently I guarantee you there are
people in rural areas of New Hampshire
whose dogs are limping and they can't
afford a vet so they take them out and
shoot them to remove their pain and we
don't have sheriffs and animal cruelty
people and whatever showing up like oh
my gosh someone just did it animals most
people don't even care about them and
here we are talking about people who
genuinely want to get kids this is
speculative it is it is a testimony I'm
sorry that's fine no no uh yeah this
really isn't to the bill and actually I
think you know we all agree that we'd
like to see animals be taken care of and
give good care and that's what we're
working on so if you have any other
comments that are specific to either the
bill or what we've talked about
specifically doing I guess just the
point is that
under this bill it seems like what
mostly what we're dealing with is people
who care enough about their animals to
want to get care that as we heard in
testimony they want to get care quickly
and as inexpensively as possibly and I
agree that animal chiropractors can and
probably should be certified in some way
to recognize pain but you can go to a
vet without referral and have the same
thing they sometimes misdiagnose and
treat an animal we're not we're not
dealing with vets
um and in fact my hope that we're not
dealing with that anyway so thank you
very much and uh there's nothing else
I'd like to give something else or
you've already indicated an intended
course of action with regard to this and
I I'm completely copacetic with that
sorry I'll do that when I hear back I'll
let people know and uh I mean if we
actually come up with an amendment then
we can have another subcommittee meeting
discuss it and vote on that
all right if there's nothing else I'll
close the uh subcommittee work session
on House Bill 258 and I'd like to open
thank you and uh
yeah right I mean representative growth
I was trying to think about just where I
was
um
so I mean as I recall
we had a lot of uh testimony on either
side on this one and um
I don't recall
any discussion of a proposed change
I mean I will yeah you know president
yes so I just want to give the history
of this bill because I think I've been
on the committee every year it's been
brought up
so the Bono contention between the
speech therapists and the music
therapist now this was the 644 which is
the blow dry bar thing oh I'm so sorry I
stepped back step back it's okay
I mean last time when we dealt with it
there was concern about uh I think we
passed in the house and there was
concern in the Senate about the gluing
the eyelid thing and the eyelashes on
and that was removed from this version
of the bill
so I just
before we get going to see who wants to
speak I was wondering if there any
thoughts or questions or whatever that
so uh I've been looking at this and
thinking about this and and I you've all
heard me say that I'm very concerned
about the aspect of uh hygiene and so
forth and
um and they're the other aspects uh so
the blow drying shampooing and so forth
is very straightforward I don't have a
problem with that at all but when they
start monking near the eyes then I'm
concerned about contamination or
our sanitation
but also my information is that this
threading thing does lead to some
bleeding
that's what I've heard okay that that
when you pull eyebrow out
that it with through threading that it
it
there is some blood that comes out
that's what I've heard we'll see if I
don't have no expertise personally on
that
um I I don't know if anyone else here
does
um so I will point out that people do
manage to cut themselves shaving as well
right so right and the world hasn't
ended right how would you know anything
about shaving Mr chairman I've observed
it but so the thing is that but also the
makeup aspect is also subject to not
that I use any but but I understand that
you have to be very careful with regard
to you don't get contamination and
transfer and and infecting somebody I
understand representative crota or oh
sorry representative a bear thank you
I have a few different thoughts shut me
down whenever you'd like to shut me down
but I don't want to shut anyone down
so my problem with this bill is just one
fact and the fact is that the
the language says that we will include
renting a chair
I believe
coming from the business background that
there is a big difference between
me owning my business certified by
as9100
and having employees that I control
monitor
um discipline
and there's a difference between me
having a subcontractor in my plant
a subcontractor is not as controlled
a subcontractor does not have to hold
the MSDS sheets that a salon owner
cosmetologist licensed cosmetologist has
to
control they have to have MSDS sheets
available
the
if I rent a chair
in a salon I am bringing with me my bag
of
hair dryer
um product yeah
right I get it all the gear I need
everything so those MSDS sheets that
have to be held by the licensed
cosmetologists
could prevent could present an issue
caught licensed cosmetologists in school
every single day are drilled on the
cleanliness sanitation and so I had an
opportunity to
um to talk about the sanitation to
understand that and so I'm going to go
back to the control of the employee
versus the subcontractor
so
lice herpes warts Phyllis colitis and
fungal infection can all happen from
lack of Sanitation so back to control I
would rather see that rental chair come
out of the bill and give the power to
the licensed cosmetologist to oversee
his or her full Salon than to risk
the required
the the requirements by oh
PLC I'm gonna get it right sometime so
look
let me at least see give in one one more
one more one more Point
um and I think the better question is
that oplc just changed their licensing
on salons from
two from four years they would re-licens
them every four years to every two years
now so if we're talking about
relinquishing licensing I believe that
we really need to start with oplc and
ask them why are you shrinking down the
licensing down to every two years now
thank you okay so actually the last
point I mean that's not part of this
bill and that's something we can you can
certainly uh contact uh executor
Courtney and ask her what what led to
that I'd like to know the answer hang on
um
just to give my view of of what's going
on here and then people can correct me
or whatever
I see that there's at least three
different situations here
um
and by the way the the uh the rental
chair thing was added not by the sponsor
originally but by it was a request of
oplc and so she added it to the bill
um
so as far as the rental thing goes
you know either that spot is being
rented to a licensed Barbara
cosmetologist esthetician
um
who can practice anything under their
scope of practice and in that case not
only is the practitioner licensed by
oplc and subject to any checking
disciplinary action or whatever but also
the Solano you know the person running
the salon is a facility license and they
also have the responsibility to oversee
what's going on in their salon
Okay so
um you know that person is running the
chair could go and you know open it up
somewhere else I mean if local zoning
allowed it to do it in their home and
they're the right equipment
um with no oversight from anybody so if
anything doing it in a licensed Salon
provides more oversight than that person
is already allowed to do now so if
anything it increases the level of
oversight that's possible than today so
that's
that's that one if this bill were to
pass
then you know in the salon the salon
owner could rent the chair out to
somebody who's not licensed as long as
they
um confine themselves to the procedures
that are permitted that this bill went
through to be not licensed so
um you know the styling the Cosmetics
blow drying and all that
um and then the other one would be that
person could practice separately not you
know in a salon you know anywhere would
be legal for them to do it
but
I don't see how being able to rent it
puts creates any more risk than exists
today because the person renting that
spot could operate somewhere else not
even in a salon at all
okay anybody else on this on anything
actually representative okay so one of
the things is my understanding is that
that the industry and the the
entrepreneurial types that we heard we
had a whole slew of them uh Institute
for justice and you know all this kind
of stuff all pushing the idea of the
salons where they're just going to be
doing
shampooing and non
cosmetology types of operations they're
going to be doing shampooing and styling
and so forth and if we permit it makeup
and threading
and I don't think they it that's what
they want to do they want to be able to
open up these non-licensed salons for
for just the simple stuff not doing
cosmetology although I suppose they
could have a cosmetologist working for
them uh because that person has their
individual license already
I don't know whether they have to work
in an individual Salon you've already
addressed I don't know the details on
that before we go further I want to ask
one question is anyone else here to
speak on 644 okay thank you
representative bear thank you um so
if if that were true
the MSDS sheets that these license Salon
has to have
filed for review by oplc
how would that work if you just open
a non-licensed place would oplc
take away the MSDS requirement by salons
what else would they take away from
salons I can't answer that my
you know there's no one here that I know
can speak on this but uh
you know my take is that if they're
licensing the facility they respond the
person running it is responsible what
happens in that facility
follow-up yes
and so furthering or moreover
then it becomes a fairness issue I
believe if if
they need to to run an alignment so
whatever we
we push through that's not licensed then
for the salon we need to
undo parts of their
oversight I don't
get that
um
there is licensing required to do I mean
assuming this bill passes they're
licensing to do some of these procedures
still and not like licensing not
required for others
um
the salon owner's response for what goes
in there they can choose to rent to a
person who's not licensed or not
um presumably they're responsible to
make sure that person
you know follows reasonable practice and
doesn't do anything that would require
licensing
but as to the details of the
the ACT licensing salons I am not an
expert so I can't answer that follow-up
sure follow-up
um so my my question then is
if we push this bill through then
anybody can go and open
anywhere that we're we're not talking
that they would rent a chair they could
just rent a place right I believe the
chair rental thing is basically separate
from the others issues in the bill so
yes
and so that just goes back to my MSDS
and all of the other requirements I
think the basic idea behind the bill is
that
I know there's some concerns but that
the activities that are being permitted
without a license are low enough risk
and they're things that people do in
their own homes regularly that worrying
about that is is not
something we would if we pass the Bill
we're choosing not to do I mean my view
is to require a license for someone to
work
um the only justification is a
significant risk to health and safety
and at least in my view and other people
have different views uh the threshold
for that is fairly high and I don't see
myself the risk of the operations there
they would allow to be unlicensed to be
high enough to justify licensing
and so I I think my final point last
point is just that oplc made these
salons put in eye wash units now as well
they have to have eye wash units in case
they
put something near somebody's eye too
so so now they have to be so once you
put an eye wash unit in it has to be
um
reviewed every I forget how many months
we have eye wash units in our own
facility they have to to be we have to
have people come in and check them and
it just it's another well this doesn't
change any of that
um and and I'm this is speculation I'm
not an expert but I believe the concern
with the iwash stations is that people
are licensed to doing other operations
are handling
um some chemicals that really could be
very bad if they got in somebody's eyes
I mean you got dyes and bleaching I
don't know what else they have so I
think that's more aimed
at them and this is not touching any of
that whatsoever
it has nothing to do with it so anybody
else want to speak in this
I will say when I when I look at this it
includes
airbrushing
which is the spraying of chemicals to
the face
that could at some point or another
enter the eye
and we don't know what all those
chemicals are that they're applying to
the face and that's my concern
the other concern I have is with
what we've talked about is sanitation
and with the threading portion of
Sanitation
when you read
the definition of threading
method of removing hair from the
eyebrows upper lip or other parts of the
body using a cotton thread to pull hair
from follicles threading also includes
the use of over-the-counter powdered
shells and scissors and tweezers
and there's nothing saying about the
sanitation of those instruments that are
being used
as they're pulling the follicles
and when you pull a follicle you're
through some sort of contamination to
enter the body and my concern is
there'll be no requirement for any
sanitation on the instruments used
anyone else want to speak on this
representative Schmidt one of the things
that we haven't discussed is uh it was
it was referenced in the hearing but
this threading apparently is something
that most people learn it's a it's kind
of a cultural thing in some uh I I don't
even know whether it's like Arabic the
Arabic world or Haitian or whatever but
the thing is it's most of the people
that do this I think learn it from their
families
okay
and so it it seems like it's something
that it may be not very widespread in
terms of how many people are out there
that could do this but as I said I'm
okay with that with the salon where
they're going to do shampooing and
styling and so forth and so on where the
lady comes in and she's going to go out
that night to a dance or an event or
whatever and she wants to have her hair
nicely styled and shampooed I get that
and apparently that's a big deal and
that's spreading all over the universe
uh just not here yet but it's the the
threading and the and the makeup I'm
much more concerned and uh and
representative goalie raises the issue
about plucking and so forth and using
instruments because you're not going to
do with your fingertips okay
um unless somebody's got something new I
think we're kind of going in circles
here a little bit uh representative a
bear
I'd like to get to
I they're not here for I like they're
here for the music therapy I believe
I know I that's why I'm trying to that's
why I'm trying to I'll close out my
comments I'll close out my comments um
so thank you Mr chairman so I am
absolutely for this bill and I think it
was best said by one of my colleagues
that we just need some guard rails on
this that we put the Power
in I'm pro-business it put the Power
with the cosmetologists and give them
the power to have and hire people that
are unlicensed to help prep answer the
phone and help prep the next
client for the coloring and etc etc
thank you all right
um
I'd like to I'm going to make a motion
of ought to pass on House Bill 644 or do
okay
um so any further discussion that we
haven't
dealt with all that uh representative
goalie thank you Mr chair I'll just
state that I will be voting against this
for those reasons that I stated earlier
okay anyone else
okay
um
like take the vote and I don't know what
order representative goli I
said no representative uh Wilhelm
um representative Bailey
uh representative a bear no and I vote
Yes
so it looks like three to two all right
I mean uh sorry two to three
so that fails would anybody want to make
I'll move in expedient to legislate
okay anybody want that okay
give me a moment here
no it's fine
uh he's there people can sit in on that
but they can't we can't vote that's
I I think that there's still some open
questions I I think you guys might want
to think in terms of retaining moving to
retain the bill
um
let's do this and then
yeah and and the full committee can do
something else so uh
uh sure what's up any comments on the
ITIL motion
so I I like the bill where we're going
but it needs guardrails so I won't be
supporting a itl and to my colleague I
hope that somebody makes a motion for
Mr chair I'll withdraw my motion and
move to retain
okay
um okay you do as well all right fine so
okay representative goalie motion is to
retain uh Hospital 644.
okay representative Wilhelm yes
representative Bailey
representative a bear yes you know the
chair boats yes and so it's five to zero
to retain
okay
so I'll close the work session on House
Bill 644 and open the work session on
House Bill
532 relative to licensure and regulation
music therapists
representative Schmidt thank you Mr
chairman well
um I I this is a bill that's already
passed the house a couple of times uh
but it hasn't made it through the whole
process in the Senate uh and but the
thing is that
this is a a viable profession that has
existed for some time it is a beneficial
profession uh we have a lady here who's
operates the salon in Dover I assume
it's not a salon but music therapy or
unless they're called salons it's an
entity
practice practice okay I apologize for
the inappropriate word uh she operates a
business I've been there
um and the and so forth and she has one
of her colleagues here and and so I
would like to see is get this going
because uh the the problem is not that
that it's it's not out there the problem
is it that most insurance companies will
not pay for the service
um unless the uh the practitioners have
a license that's the issue I understand
and actually I I recognize that music
therapy can be very valuable
um I had a wife of a good friend former
rep actually and who was also a good
friend who did cancer did Hospice at
home and she had people I mean they
weren't licensed music therapists but
people who came and the porch and played
music for it from a music group she used
to be in so and it helped her and and
you know and I'm not challenging
anything about the value of music
therapy
um what I will say I mean before we go
on and I will have them come up and
speak but uh my objection is that given
um
that licensing a profession limits
people that can get into it it's having
the government say you can't do this
unless you follow our rules
I do not see creating a license for the
purpose of allowing you know permitting
insurance
reimbursement is a I see that as a
misuse of the whole idea of Occupational
licensing maybe something else needs to
be done
somewhere else dealing with insurance
companies or something else but I mean
that that's my position on that but
good morning
can you give me your uh name uh yes so
um I'm the chair of the New Hampshire
music therapy task force for State
recognition and I do also own a business
a music therapy practice I have 10
employees I believe eight of us are
music therapy uh board certified
and we serve probably about 3 500 people
across the state of New Hampshire
um so I I want to
I want to take time most of the time to
really answer questions that you have
but I just want to say
um I hear what you're saying that the
insurance shouldn't be the only reason
why
why someone passes a licensure but the
other really big piece of this is
protecting the public from people using
the term music therapy and you know
um
and there's a there is a potential for
harm so music has actual there's loads
and loads of research on this uh music
has actual physical effects on our body
so music can lower or increase your
heart rate music can lower your
respiration rate
um music can
um cause your like neurological
stimulation that certain people with
certain abilities or disabilities I
should say are not able to process
um and can be like put them in a state
of a medical emergency people anyone can
use music in a therapeutic way but board
certified music therapists are trained
to respond to the first of all we're
trained not to use music in a way that's
going to be harmful to recognize when
we're working with someone who is at
risk for you know using music at a
certain decibel or to recognize when
we're working with someone who has
experienced
trauma that certain Like lyrics and
music could be triggering and could
um
could put that person into a state of
psychosis that you know we're just
really trained in how to respond to all
of those things whereas you know
somebody who is a well-trained musician
and loves people and loves caring for
people could go into you know
a nursing home and like play music
kindly for a group of dementia patients
and then
they could be kind of triggered into a
state of like dis like disorientation
um which could have multiple physical
effects on their body and and then that
person is kind of like oh I don't I
don't know what to do with this because
I just came here to make some nice music
for people and so the licensure piece
really takes the state saying okay like
there is a potential for harm here
for an untrained person
and so these people are trained they're
educated they've gone through rigorous
clinical experience and they
um they are able to call themselves call
this music therapy they are able to say
this is music therapy
the having somebody walk into a hospital
and say oh yeah I I don't know how many
times I have encountered someone in the
grocery store and told them I'm a music
therapist and they've said oh I do music
therapy
I put music I put music on my car I'm a
music therapist and that's not what
we're trained for we don't go to I don't
have hundreds of thousands of dollars in
Masters in like School Education Loans
because I play music in my car or like I
tell someone I don't tell people to like
lay on a couch and listen to music and
you're going to be all better that's not
what we're trained for it's it's more
rigorous it's more intentional than that
um and so there you know
you wouldn't go to like a dentist and
I guess like ask them to like look at
the bones in your fingers
um and so like what we do is really
specific
oh
so I want to provide some history to
this Cruise committee on this bill so
this has been
um a bill that has been before the
committee
and the original
um issue with the bill was that speech
pathologists
and music therapists the lines of
demarcation were fuzzy
and the speech pathologists were
concerned and so this language that's in
the bill that's been amended
is agreeable to the speech pathologists
and to the
um music therapists so I think that this
is a big step that was taken
um and
I think so it's the only change to is to
eliminate some conflict
right well yeah that's a big deal right
because we want the music therapists and
the speech pathologists to
at least have an idea of where their
fields separate and where they can work
together and that was the issue that
because oftentimes speech pathologists
and music therapists work together
to address
issues that children might have for
example what I'd like to do is just
proceed with the the underlying issue of
Licensing or not licensing music
therapists
and then you know we could consider the
amendment if we choose to go down to
licensing route
sense so what you're saying is you're
going to ignore the amendment and you're
just going to try to handle the bill as
it is which is applaud my
I mean my intent is to offer an itl
motion on the bill and I would offer the
same if it were amended because my
objection to the bill has got nothing to
do with the conflict between music
therapy and speech therapy
um I don't know that would make sense I
mean and maybe I'll lose and maybe then
we'll go on to take care of the
amendment or maybe that'll be done in
the full committee
um
thank you
yes you're you're first yeah right may I
address your first question would you
please introduce yourself first yes my
answer is Rebecca gilday I am a Music
therapist in the state of New Hampshire
and what was your last name gilday
g-i-l-d-e-a okay thank you yeah
um so the one of the things that you
said was
um you're concerned that licensure would
um prevent music therapists from working
in the state and
um actually what our our issue currently
is that music therapists are having a
really hard time working in the state at
all
um it's very difficult to have a job in
the state of New Hampshire
um because of the sources of payment for
music therapy services
um
it has the the growth rate for music
therapists for jobs in music therapy has
been unbelievably slow in the state in
comparison to other states especially in
comparison to States who have passed
music therapy licensure their their jobs
have increased significantly once
licensure was passed
um and it's not because music therapy is
not effective it's not because it's not
um
efficacious and and medically necessary
for some folks it's because there are
barriers to
um seeking services and primarily that
comes around
um
the it comes around either having
uh private pay
or some kind of grant funding which is
severely limited and if we are if we're
wanting to bolster business and bolster
young people coming to our state
um
we want to make that job growth and job
Avenue as as helpful as possible
um and so this licensure bill is going
to
to help that and it's not saying that
um like to become a music therapist you
already have a set of regulations you
have to meet that's already set by the
um
by the certification board of Music
therapists it's a national accreditation
agency so anyone wanting to go into the
field already has a set of standards
that they have to do
um but when after they do all of that
when they have to look at what the job
market is the they travel out they they
don't come back to New Hampshire because
we have what three four agencies for
music therapy agencies three in the
entire State and there's only 48 music
therapists working here either privately
or through those agencies
thank you
and to follow up and comment on that the
we have at least 60 percent of our music
therapists in the state living in New
Hampshire and working in in other states
driving and working in other states
because they just can't get reimbursed
for their work here okay I have a
question that maybe you folks can answer
in states where it is licensed Does
Medicare or Medicaid provide
reimbursement for music therapy yes okay
thank you
um oh also
um I mean just there is a music
therapist
um and I am bling I'm totally forgetting
what state it is but I have it in an
email somewhere who works in a hospital
setting they're employed by the hospital
and when their state passed licensure
the hospital gave them a 40
000 raise
just because they had a license so like
that's just showing you why people are
wanting to go to places that have
licensure because if you had the choice
of like oh I can maybe make ten thousand
dollars a year or I can make fifty
thousand dollars a year I'm gonna go to
the place where I can make an actual
living I'm gonna go
I have you know I understand yeah any
question my represent goalie
not really question Mr chair just a
comment if I may certainly
as we heard in testimony when this came
before us
a number of folks testified that this
helped out
and we heard in testimony that
doing
the wrong type of therapy
can have
bad effects on individuals
and the most moving for me was when you
have a Vietnam veteran up there looking
for care
and having to pay out of his own pocket
for that care that obviously is helping
him and he told us it was helping him
and it was very helpful
is the reason why I will support this
okay
anyone else
um
I mean I mentioned earlier what my view
is and just want to say that it's not
it's not just me I'm not this a mean
person over here there are quite a
number of states I don't know the number
who before a new um
occupational life a new profession can
be licensed by the state before law can
go in place to create an occupational
license
and before the legislature can consider
it there's a requirement and this is
kind of like you know we have fiscal
notes on the bills there's a requirement
that a um a group which is
it's under the executive branch but as
independent as possible
looks you know it looks into well first
of all the legislature is set up what
are the justifications for having
general justifications for creating you
know requiring a license for a
profession
and so what they're tasked with is
taking a look at the new profession
looking for license
and seeing if that if the license is
Justified under
um you know under that list of
requirements and they get people to come
in and give testimony and and all of
that and generate reports I've skimmed
through some of them
I didn't read them all there's one of
them it's almost 300 Pages because it's
got everybody's testimony but uh just to
give an ex there are eight states
that have done this kind of a review on
occupational licensing poor music
therapists specifically
one of the states actually did it twice
and in all but one case they their
conclusion was there was not a
justification
for licensing occupational therapists
and and those are
I mean Colorado they did it twice
because there was a second attempt Utah
Washington West Virginia Nebraska and
even our neighbor Vermont rejected
licensing for music therapy
um
one of the criteria that makes it
Justified to have
a license was set up
the reimbursement issue none of the
states included the reimbursement issue
and and my view is that that is a
completely there I recognize there's a
problem uh maybe it needs to be fixed
somewhere else
but in my view it's a complete it's
abuse of the concept of Occupational
licensing to create an occupational
license largely for the purpose of
Permitting reimbursement and all of
those States actually did look at
um the risk issue on occupational
licensing and actually I'll I'll forward
a thing that has links out to all of
them for anybody who wants to look at
them some of them actually have
uh you know each individual small
concern raised by music therapists to
justify the license and their analysis
of it and also at least one maybe more
uh did a survey of every incident where
there was any report of somebody having
any kind of a harm
based on occupational therapy in the
dinner analysis of that
um so I will send that around sorry I
didn't do it earlier I just got access
to it in the last couple days
so anyway unless there's more discussion
um I'll make them I'll actually I'll
make a motion of itl on House Bill 532
representative goalie thank you Mr chair
and I will once again say we heard
numerous testimony
unfortunate that
a lot of those individuals if unless
they can pay out of pocket will not get
the services they need or we'll have to
travel to another state that offers that
service
and it's also sorry interrupt I I
neglect to get a second somebody second
that
really okay thank you sorry continue and
it's
also
unfortunate that we are losing a number
of workers here in this state because of
that reason and they are leaving the
state for that and
in doing so leaves a hole in a very
important service to a number of
individuals including our veterans okay
thank you anyone else represent Wilhelm
thank you Mr chair I I find it really
troubling that in the middle of a mental
health crisis in our state we would not
recognize
uh qualified therapists uh who can help
in a different way to increase access to
resources to a whole variety of folks
that need it whether we're talking about
veterans whether we're talking about
young people whether we're talking about
Hospice Care
um I I just find it uh really uh sad to
to
think that not increasing the number of
professionals
um you know knowing that sixty percent
of uh therapists live who who are
qualified in the state of New Hampshire
are leaving the state uh to provide
therapy that's a lack of therapeutic
resources
uh that could be in the state of New
Hampshire that's that's leaving the
state every day
um and so I'll be voting against the
ideal motion all right thank you and I
just want to make clear that I mean my
position is in no way an indication that
I don't think music therapy can be
valuable
um
but I would explain my reason I don't
I too find it puzzling and not just in
this case but we've heard dozens of
these things that we need a license to
get reimbursed it seems like at some
point we should be following that up to
what causes that and make it stop
I I agree
um I'm sure you turn
um we're not at this point actually if
you turn the mic off and thank you for
Testimony
um yeah representative Wilhelm thank you
chairman you know I guess without some
sort of other mechanism to
you know it's like we're we're working
within the system that is and so uh you
know just another reason why I'm gonna
post the idea I understand certainly
um representative a bear
thank you Mr chairman my question to one
of my colleagues questions is is is
there anything on the horizon to
to be able to accept insurance through
the legislature
legislature I'll give you my answer and
if anybody else has more and that is I
I mean in in theory uh you know we
regulate insurance companies and we
could do something about that maybe
uh say they had to require it not just
for someone's license but maybe if they
had nationally certified uh sort of
recognized certification
um however I and the legislature don't
have a lot of influence on the federal
government and they're an issue as well
a representative Schmidt
thank you Mr chairman
I think one of the reasons that uh
you have to have a license in order to
get paid by the insurance companies so
that you get people who are actually
trained and qualified because it is a
profession
they won't pay just like if you've got a
Doctor Who's got all the training in the
world but he's had his or her license
revoked for moral turpitude
financial fraud or whatever I think we
got the idea and I I understand that um
I mean there are ways other than
um licensing to deal with it so
I don't know is there anybody have
anything else I think it's we need to
move on if that's all right because we
have other things to deal with
okay so uh representative goalie
no representative Wilhelm no represent
Bailey
representative a bearer no and uh I vote
no so that's
three to two
um we've adopted the itl and and I
understand others disagree and I
understand the reasons why and
um
we can what happens
oh I'm sorry you voted no on the ITIL I
am just confused sorry
it's that you had itl no no no all that
okay all right so the motion fails let's
find anyone might make another motion
yeah
thank you chairman I I'd like to uh
introduce Amendment uh zero four
second
okay
so
um
representative grotta if that's if this
is the amendment you came up with if you
can kind of give a little more of an
overview of just of course thank you
this um this amendment was submitted by
both
um Asha which is the speech pathologist
group and the music therapist and it was
there um
and they both support this amendment and
it does talk about
um the different delineations between
the two professions and where they work
together so it's it's it is a it was the
first time actually that we've had this
Clarity between the two professional
groups and so I I hope that the
committee will adopt it because it is
important thank you
thank you um
let me tell you where it yeah how does
it differ
um you know I mean not and it doesn't
have to be an enormous detail but some
idea I can tell you where there it takes
the the current bill thing
so it takes the current bill and adds
section three
where it says um
collaborating with the individualized
family services where is this I'm so
sorry it's line
19. on the amendment that yeah that line
great thank you that line was added
along with on the next line
collaborating with the client's
treatment team including the this is the
part that was added including the
client's physician
psychologists
licensed clinical social worker and
other mental health professional during
the provision of Music Therapy Services
to the client
um
you know maybe has either on their own
starting new or they've had music
therapy in the past and they want to see
a music therapist and you know however
it's going to be paid for would this
require would this prevent them from
doing that if they don't have a
no it's only if they had this was the
issue oh there's an or yes exactly and
this was one of the issues that we had
come across in previous in the previous
bills was because there were there was
no
statement as to how these would they
would interweave during in these
positions where there was a treatment
team this is new language to the
um
I just caught the ore which takes okay
sorry I just don't didn't want that to
be a requirement in all cases correct
and
and this and the rest and this the
change to RSA 360 but that change about
um not representing the public is that
the same basically yes
okay
those are the only changes really that
were made um
line
all right actually I'm fine with it and
uh I mean I intend to vote for the
amendment whatever I think of the
underlying bill I think this you know
is a good change in case the bill does
pass so
right any other discussion well the
thing is that there was always objection
an opposition as you know from speech
pathologist because it's kind of like
you're doing this no we're not yes you
are I understand conflict of scope of
practice Yeah
anybody else
representative a bear
thank you
um I am planning on supporting this for
a couple of reasons but I I want to be
on record for why I'm rep why I'm
supporting it
um so number one you know most people
don't come in and ask to be licensed
they ask to not be licensed
um
what I mean is by regulated more
regulation more we want less regulation
than more right I think the experience
of the committee is that most licenses
come about because the people in the
profession has to be licensed okay
thank you for the correction no no at
least not all I would say lately we've
had a good number of releasing the
licensing or really look at the hair
blowing thing and the you know and the
let's read let's get rid of licenses all
together I get that you know but but I
think a new license is at least as long
I haven't been here as long as others
but from what I've seen for new ones
that tends to be people in the business
coming in looking for it
maybe I'm I'm wrong but anyway sorry
thank you
um so
I I am pro-business I I agree with that
I agree with one of my colleagues
regarding mental health if it helps
um and this does not hit our taxpayers
because you would be paying the
licensing fees as a business
so I am
um for Less taxes
um so pro-business less taxes and
um freedom to want to do this is why I
will support this thank you okay thank
you anyone else
okay
um so the motion
yes sir I just wanted to say I I think
this amendment represents a a real big
step forward given the uh the agreement
um you know between other providers and
music therapists and I agree and um
I mean I know were you the one who was
involved in negotiating this deal with
them
that's that's that's uh that's laudable
certainly yes and I guess just to wrap
up my point it's it what it says is
there's a need for more
licensed therapists and I think given
everything that we're dealing with with
the Mental Health crisis I I think this
is a big step in the right direction all
right that's fine
um if you know are there any other
comments I don't wanna all right so um
we're voting on whether or not to adopt
Amendment uh zero four eight zero h
um representative goalie yes
representative Wilhelm yes
representative Bailey yes
uh representative a bearer yes and I
vote Yes and so the uh the amendment
we're recommending to the committee the
amendment be adopted
um
all right anybody else want to make a
motion
to pass with Amendment
okay any any further discussion or I
think we've said everything needs to be
I agree but I have to give people a
chance
um
okay representative goalie
yes represent Wilhelm yes representative
Bailey
no representative a bearer yes and I
vote no so the motion passes three to
two
and I'm closing the work session on
House Bill 532 and I think we're done
and thank you everyone
foreign
that's like yeah
my view on motion to adjourn all in
you need to fill out these sheets so you
foreign